I get to talk to you about webassembly
I'm gonna try and demystify it a little
bit it's a very complex topic so you
know it's it's a there's a lot of things
to cover and what this means for node
it's pretty even more complicated than
what webassembly is so Who am I I'm Jay
Phelps I used to work at Netflix but
recently I left to start a company with
my friend Tracy called this dot and what
we do at this dot is we do lots of
different things when you support
training mentorship stuff we do
developer relations and then we also do
staff augmentation and stuff like that
so if this is interesting to you
webassembly or not-- or any of these
type of things feel free to reach out so
let's get started what is webassembly
well it's also known as well
or was um depending on how you'd like to
pronounce it I personally pronounced it
wasa m-- and it the the spiel is that
it's an efficient low-level byte code
for the web but there's one thing in
this talk particular that I want to do
is I want to scratch out that last part
for the web really web assembly is just
an efficient low-level byte code the
fact that they're creating it for the
web is kind of a secondary thing it's
this is actually a very unprecedented is
a where instruction set that so think
about like the Intel instruction set or
the arm instruction set these are things
that were created proprietary by like
singular companies whereas webassembly
all the major companies came together
and created this for all of them like
they basically all the preferences and
all the desires for those companies came
together so I think that's very
important to clarify that so let's break
this down a little bit what do I mean by
efficient well I'm gonna mean that it's
fast to load and fast to execute so if
you're using web assembly in a browser
it's gonna be fast to send over the
internet so small bundle sizes are very
important but then also fast to compile
and parse times you know there's been a
big push recently with javascript to get
those parse times down because even if
you've got your bundle size less than a
megabyte there's still a ton of time
being spent on that and so web assembly
was designed with that in mind with
those problems in mind and so there's
something called streaming compilation
and this doesn't actually apply to node
because
the files are obviously sitting on your
hard drive but it's really important to
know especially if you're going to be
doing things like isomorphic webassembly
like you're gonna running it on the node
but also running it in the browser and
streaming compilation essentially just
means like we've got this this mobile
device here and let's imagine that we've
got some web assembly on the server and
we want to send that to it it's going to
get compiled to machine code as soon as
that the download is complete but with
streaming compilation we can actually
compile it as chunks are coming across
the wire so before it's even done we've
compiled everything up to that point and
in many cases it can compile faster than
it can download especially in like
browsers like Firefox and Chrome so
let's take a look at that again just to
make sure we're clear so the chunks of
the web assembly module get compiled and
they're finished compiling even before
the next chunk has started so that's
really important for the the browser
story but it's also a low-level bytecode
what does that really mean well it's it
means that there's instructions that are
actual bytes this is very similar to
machine code right it's a binary thing
and that means it's mostly intended as a
compilation target this is not something
that everyone in this room is going to
be writing by hand you can write it by
hand just like you can write assembly by
hand like machine code assembly but it's
not intended to be that way it's
intended to take code like this this is
C or C++ either and compile that to the
the hexadecimal binary representation on
the right so you compile it ahead of
time and one of the most popular
questions that I get asked about web
assembly is is this gonna kill
JavaScript right is that the intent of
this and really the answer to that is no
it's that's it's definitely not the
intent to kill JavaScript it's really
just to give another option so think
about how many languages today are
actually compiling to JavaScript and
JavaScript is a terrible compilation
target so this is really just giving you
another option for that it's designed
specifically for compilation but maybe
in a long time from now it will decrease
the usage of JavaScript and our reliance
on it especially as new brand new
languages like reason and Elm get
invented and we may start to pivot
towards those languages but is
certainly not the intent and
JavaScript's not going anywhere anytime
soon so the next question would be am I
going to compile my JavaScript to
webassembly
you know if it has that streaming
compilation benefits and all that stuff
why wouldn't I just compile JavaScript
web assembly and the answer is super
complex it really is really complex and
there's a lot of nuance so you can it's
easy to get into arguments about this
but the general high-level gist is
JavaScript is just an extremely dynamic
language just really extremely dynamic
and like here's a very simple example of
this that not commonly known the but but
due to the prototype inheritance how it
works if you act you can actually call
push on the prototype of array and
totally screw up every array that ever
gets created in JavaScript in that
engine now it has it's actually
technically empty it has a length of 0
but if you access the first item it
actually exists and it causes issues
with map and all sorts of problems and
this is totally spec compliant it's just
JavaScript is a very complex a very
dynamic runtime based behavior so
compiling you know strict JavaScript
like compiling everything that could
possibly be JavaScript web assembly
would over all be slower the virtual
machines in your browsers are and in
node our tremendous they're great use
javascript if you want to use javascript
but and this is where the arguments
start is what if you do you use a strict
subset of JavaScript right there's
there's been a whole bunch of
experiments about this like turbo
scripts and assembly script where they
take the same syntax as JavaScript this
looks like typescript for example and
you can compile that down to web
assembly because there's a lot of you
know like the all the dynamic portions
of it that we don't use super often but
are certainly possible you just get rid
of those right so it's not JavaScript
but it's close enough and so that is
certainly possible and there's been a
bunch of experiments in fact Facebook
just recently when I say recently I mean
just a couple days ago created a PR on
their project called pre pack 2 where
they were they pre-processed JavaScript
actually try and evaluate it ahead of
time to figure out what they can
statically know about it and they've
actually been experimenting with with
taking certain parts of a strict subset
of JavaScript and compiling that to web
assembly stew super super early and it's
it doesn't work with very complex
JavaScript objects and stuff but it's
exciting to see what people will do with
this but that is not the intent
piling your JavaScript web assembly is
not what you're going to do overall so
the v1 is primary suited the the MVP of
web assemblies for languages like C++ or
rust these are low level system
languages where you don't use garbage
collection where you manually manage
your memory and really the abstractions
in the language is syntactic sugar for
loads and stores of numbers inside of a
linear memory right this is very
low-level type of languages but other
languages are a stated goal of web
assembly they're just taking a very
incremental process to the specification
so languages like go and and the.net
runtime and all these new languages like
reason and elements stuff like that
which are garbage collection garbage
collected they all definitely be
compiling to web assembly and in fact go
has been experimenting with this even
though web assembly is not a good target
for it right now with the v1 they've
already been experimenting with them
they're rolling their own garbage
collector and they've been working
around some of the limitations of web
assembly to experiment it's not the most
performant at this point for go but
someday it will be so currently right
now when should a you target web
assembly know I'm not talking about the
future but right now when should you do
it well the gist is that heavily CPU
number computations whenever you're
doing anything which just basically
boils down to a bunch of numbers and
you'd be surprised what that actually is
in a lot of apps and in fact you a lot
of people in this room especially if
you've done any browser stuff may
already be using web assembly and you
don't even know it and so one example of
that is the Mozilla folks they there's a
project called source map so anyone who
pretty much deals with source map in any
way whether Babel less SAS all these
things they all use this library
including Firefox itself the chrome the
Firefox developer tools uses this
library and it used to be written in
JavaScript but they ported it to rust
and compiled that to web assembly and
they saw an over 10x speed improvement
which is huge especially for you know
your local development type of stuff
that's a huge improvement for me and
then many of you are probably already
using that today another use case is
going to be as an alternative to writing
native or napi there was an earlier talk
about the end a new n API and instead of
writing native truly native add-ons
which require you know it to be compiled
when you NPM
install it you could write you didn't
put you could write it in C++ and then
compile that to webassembly now there's
this is not necessarily a paved path
this point so there's a lot of hairiness
to that but there's already been people
experimenting with this my friend OJ
Kuan for example libsass is a very
popular project which is a native
implementation of a SAS compiler but one
of the issues with that is the fact that
when you npm install it it has to get
compiled for your machine it takes a
really long time there's security
concerns about doing that and it's not
portable right that that same library
can't be trivially used in the browser
as well and so webassembly he's been
experimenting with and this actually
works there's just some edge case
caveats and then he's gonna do a legwork
to try and get that upstream but there's
already been a bunch of libraries and
algorithms and stuff these are just a
some examples that I know of off the top
of my head that have been ported to
compile to web assembly these are all
available on NPM you can npm install
these today and they run with web
assembly transparently so you could also
use node for example as a portable
sandbox in fact I've spoken with a lot
of people here today who actually have
considered this and a couple companies
that are actually experimenting with it
today to basically using node is just a
fancy very solid and well secured
sandbox because there's there's
complicated reasons but the web assembly
itself has there's a whole class of
exploits like buffer overflow exploits
that are not even possible even if you
wrote it in a high-level language where
it would be possible like a traditional
C++ or C buffer over overflow exploit
can't be done in web assembly you can
still overflow and your app may crash
but you won't be able to jump to
arbitrary executable code and stuff like
that so let's go take a step back a
little bit and look at what was that
binary stuff that I showed earlier you
know we got that and if you're like me
you might be looking at this and going
well this just sounds awful like you
know that's it's just overwhelming what
are you doing and and that's just
because binary can obviously be
intimidating I don't look at this at the
binary and go oh I know exactly what
that's doing I read that you know it's
like the matrix where I don't even see
the code no no no you know the pro tip
is don't worry about the binary that's
an implementation detail
if you've ever written Swift or
objective-c or even any native apps you
know how often do you actually
go and look at the machine code itself
you know after college probably not a
whole lot and that's because tooling
should save you from that right tooling
you should make it so that that that
information you don't need to know the
binary stuff but unfortunately we are
early adopters on web assembly if you're
gonna be using it right now and so
tooling is not quite there to prevent
you from needing to know it at all so
there is a textual representation of the
web assembly that can save the day for
you and so that same binary can be
expressed in this textual way like this
this is a textual assembly and you may
be thinking looking at that going well
that's better but I still don't
understand what the heck that is and so
let's take it's just a second to learn
the fundamentals of what web assembly is
how it actually evaluates so web
assembly is a stack machine language
it's not a register machine that's the
the opposite of that it's a stack
machine and so well what is a stack
machine well it's important to truly
know that you know a stack is a data
structure where you've got two
operations you can push or pop you can't
access in the middle if you push
something the only way to get something
off of it is you have to pop it and so a
stack machine is a machine in which
instead the instructions are evaluated
as a stack so whenever you have a you
have an instruction it's going to be
pushing or popping things on this
intrinsic stack as part of the machine
itself instead of needing to manage a
separate stack so let's take a look at
an actual example 1+2 one of the
simplest things well on the left you
have the bytecode for it's for the
actual opcode for the add instruction
and webassembly on the on the right
you've got the textual representation of
it the mnemonic as it's called but you
can just call it the textual
representation and so that's the add
instruction and so this would be all you
would need to do to add that one plus
two together let's kind of break that
down with a stack visualization we've
got the one so that's going to that's
basically telling the machine put one on
us on the stack so that's what we do
we've got the two it's saying put two on
the stack that's gonna go on top of that
and then we've got another instruction
saying the add and that's gonna say take
the two previous operands off the stack
add them together so take the previous
two off the stack magically somehow
machine add them together and then push
the result onto the stack so now the
result of that
or that after that instruction has been
evaluated is three so if we wanted to
log that value out how would you do that
well you'd need to slide in a call log
right after that right after it that's
assuming that log is a magical function
that accepts an integer but but the the
argument to that log would be the result
of the stack above it so this is a
little confusing still and most people
are actually going to look at what's
called an abstract syntax tree syn
version of that textual representation
and this is this is like here here's the
example we have with the 1 plus 2 and
the log we can represent this instead
like this and this is much more familiar
and you don't need to know anything
about stack machines and if these are
called s expressions and if any one is
thinks it looks kind of funny yeah it
does look like lisp if if you're
familiar with that older language but
it's still used today and you can see
that it's kind of like saying function
calls right it's kind of like saying the
function call ad and it's got the two
arguments and then the function call log
and it's got the the singular argument
so let's kind of look at what's missing
in webassembly I've been talking about
some of the high-level stuff and we kind
of did a little bit of a deep dive into
how does web assembly actually get
evaluated what is missing today to be
productive in like the the the node type
of environment well the biggest thing
that you'll quickly figure out is that
web assembly today has no direct access
to any kind of host api's not in the
browser not in node you can basically
load and store from memory and do a
bunch of number crunching but as far as
like logging or signals or any kind of
host interaction nothing is directly
exposed to it instead right now you have
to give it things via JavaScript so when
you load up a web assembly module which
you have to do currently from JavaScript
you have to give it imports you have to
essentially dynamically link any kind of
external type of side effects so if you
need to read from a file or you need to
you know access a WebSocket or whatever
it is those type of things have to be
exposed to web assembly and so that can
you know it's not the end of the world
there's a bunch of people there's
projects like M script in which has done
a lot of legwork on the C standard
library but it's
it's not ideal right and there so it is
a goal of webassembly to eventually
somehow expose native host bindings
somehow in the browser that's gonna be
the dom most likely and node the
question is kind of a much more complex
does that mean it's it's providing the
note the standard node modules like you
know the FS and all that the questions
are a little open and especially with n
api so one of the I've been I've been
talking here at the conference with a
couple people who directly worked on the
N API stuff and the you know there's the
open question of well with web assembly
does that is that going to replace an
API and the answer is to that currently
is no ultimately it's a really note is a
really big ship and so steering and
turning that ship takes a very long time
and a lot of effort and so NEP I the
plan and experiment with that would have
been you know several years in the
making before it was even clear whether
web assembly was actually going to
become a thing and so they're
considering web assembly and what that
doesn't mean for the future but it's too
early at this point in fact they kind of
are hoping that the community will kind
of experiment in you experimenting to
figure out what worked what didn't work
and then what can be pulled out and and
made a standard part of note itself but
regardless if you're using node with web
assembly you're probably going to have
to access JavaScript at some point so
one of the other problems is garbage
collection we need access to the native
v8 garbage collector somehow and there's
proposals right now that I've been
working worked on for the last couple
years to expose that in some way and and
it's definitely coming but currently
that's not possible so you can't
actually pass like a JavaScript object
into web assembly you could like use
like a week map and then like create
your own like convention of like a
pointer that you know it's just a number
that you pass into web assembly that
actually is stored in some sort of table
and JavaScript to reference that but you
can't pass JavaScript objects into web
assembly or access them inside
webassembly natively because you
wouldn't be able to garbage collect them
the the next thing is multi-threading
this is one of the things that'll when
people reach for languages like C++ or
rust they're said they're often doing so
because they need that they need the
real true multi-threading stuff and this
is actually possible today with web
assembly and it uses workers under the
hood but you do it with it's all
transparent the worker
stuff is all transparent so you don't
have to use message-passing because if
something called shared array buffer the
only caveat to that is that in the
browser shared array buffers is disabled
they launched it and then they pulled it
out because of the specter and meltdown
exploits but it's actually available in
node so you can actually do
multi-threading in node and so you if
you use something like I'm scripting
which is a project to help you compile
your C++ to web assembly it will
transfer you when you use P threads it
will just transparently actually use
workers under the hood and handle that
all for you but there has been
discussions workers are not trivial as
far as the cost to spin them up they're
actually kind of expensive in the grand
scheme of things so there has been talk
in the committee about like what do what
does native P threads look like and the
reason why they haven't given that from
the day one is is ultimately they have
to be careful of exposing true true
parallelism to JavaScript itself because
you could use web assembly as the
intermediary so in web workers it
protects you against that because if you
access the web assembly function that
happens to use true multi-threading in
JavaScript you can't you can't bypass
that some magical way you have to use
postmessage to be able to to do that so
it's like I said it's kind of a little
complicated but P true P threads are
probably most likely coming later so
there's a bunch of other proposals as
well and in as far as node goes we
basically are trying to look for more
people who are interested in this type
of thing so that they can join the
community group and inform us what do
you want to webassembly to to look like
in the nodes in the node ecosystem so in
that to that to that point how do you
get started like after this talk if
you're really excited just to take a
look and start to do too early adopt
well the the most simplest is obviously
web assembly dot org where you can learn
more about the actual spec but if you're
looking for community resources there's
awesome wasum repo which is updated
really really frequently it's almost
exhaustive resource of different
projects the different languages that
compile to it different videos and
documentation all sorts of stuff there's
a lot of really great stuff and I
wondered also mentioned that this has
actually been supported since v8 r v8
sorry version 8 of v8 and it's actually
been supported but prior to that if
you're ok with using a flag and there
really wasn't any difference between
the flagged and unflagged versions and
if you're curious even though this is a
note conference I do want to point out
that it's actually supported in all
browsers today except for Internet
Explorer obviously which will never be
supported in but although all the modern
browsers they're all behind this they're
all part of the committee this is this
is a very unprecedented amount of work
that they've all come together and
collaborated on so the the thing I want
to kind of wrap up is just to talk about
how I really am obsessed with this if
you can't tell and I think it's a
revolution I think the biggest node is
definitely an unanswered question of
because there's not a lot of people who
have been experimenting with this in in
node relatively speaking and so I'm
really interested if you're interested
in this I really want to talk to you
here about your use cases I've in fact
I've already done that quite a bit even
on day one so I'm hoping after this this
will inspire some people who want to
come up to me and tell me what are you
currently using your C++ for and how can
we integrate that with node how can we
improve that experience so I just wanted
to thank you and if you have any
questions or if you are really
interested in web assembly and you want
to hear me tweet about it you can follow
me at underscore Jay Phelps on Twitter
no thank you
[Applause]